ce chaos à l'aéroport et flo on observe
un peu partout sur la planète le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que l'industrie
du voyage traverse une période
d'intenses turbulences est ce que c'est
encore possible de trouver des aubaines
et de voyager l'esprit tranquille en ce
moment j'en parle avec frédérique
lalonde et les co fondateur et pdg de
l'application de voyages aux preuves en
somme sur la longue
bonsoir les prix des hôtels au canada
ils ont grimpé de 40% depuis un an à peu
près aux etats unis c'est en moyenne 20%
de plus qu'en 2019 les prix explosent
pour le transport aérien les restaurants
ça coûte plus cher ce que est ce que
c'est pareil partout sur la langue
oui tout à fait dans tous les pays qui
sont ouverts qui est à peu près
l'amérique du nord l'europe en deux
parties on a vu une explosion de la
demande qui a commencé au début de cette
année par exemple en ce moment si je
regarde au canada on a 400 % plus de
demandes de recherche de billets de lyon
par jour qu'on avait au début de l'année
donc au début du mois de janvier 2022 ça
c'est pas seulement sur l'application à
perth et en général dans toutes les
applications tous les sites et
l'explication est simple pendant la
pandémie la plupart des gens surtout
canada pendant deux ans n'ont tout
simplement pas eu l'opportunité de
voyager à l'extérieur du pays et la
demande s'est accumulée et quand les
frontières ouvertes on a vu à
l'explosion qu'on voit c'est moi qui ai
repris un peu de chemin du tricot oui
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est une
demande très soutenue or des capacités
plus limité surtout en raison on
l'évoqué le premier de manque de
personnel est ce que dans cet équilibre
c'est encore possible de trouver des
voyages abordable
oui entre les lignes aériennes ont réagi
dès le début du printemps en augmentant
les prix ont peu parlé des prix moyens
si on regarde absolument qu'on parle de
choses si on regarde les prix
domestiques dont quatre au canada en ce
moment on est à peu près à 450 dollars
pour un billet moyen et c'est ça ça
correspond à peu près où on était en
2019 donc il comprend d'inflation
structurelles évidemment pas dans
l'après-midi près de chuter on est
revenu à peu près au même niveau à
l'international dont quand on quitte le
canada en europe ou ailleurs on parle
d'une augmentation de 20% l'ampli plus
moyens sont à neuf
c'est certain que si vous cher chez à
voyager au cours de l'été vous allez
payer plus cher la demande à
l'international à
revenir lentement affaires du pays mais
à cause des problèmes entre les
conditionner les prix sont plus élevés
qu'il ya quelques trucs qu'on peut
utiliser pour sauver de l'argent car la
première chose c'est d'utiliser un
système qui fait un suivi des prix en
temps réel comme d'application la raison
c'est que avant s'attend à des baisses
de prix à la paire l'été et les pièges
et saint joseph oui pourquoi on s'attend
des baisses de prix
c'est parce que ces années c'est parce
qu'il ya moins de gens qui voyagent à la
fin où les vacances la construction au
québec les meilleures dates pour aller
chercher un bon prix ça va vraiment être
certains mots comme ça c'est à tous les
années c'est toujours aimé le style donc
si vous n'avez par exemple pas enfin à
l'école et vous avez l'option de voyage
il plus tard dans la saison s'ils sont
que vous avez sauvé de l'argent l'autre
truc que je vais vous donner à tout le
monde si vous regardez des départs qui
sont en milieu de semaine c'est pas
toujours garanti mais généralement c'est
moins cher de partir
ensuite une on écrivait hier que les
croisières en particulier sont une
option plus d'économies que d'autres
formules à l'international est ce que
vous constatez vous qu'il ya certains
types de séjours qui sont plus
intéressants que d'autres en ce moment
qui fonctionne très très fort c'est les
déplacements en voiture
la popularité pour un paquet de raisons
entre autres aux états unis on a
remarqué un certain ralentissement de
l'économie sont de vue suite jalons de
la porte est les gens même en ce moment
qu'ils ont vu par exemple le prix de
l'or est menée par takara de monter ont
moins d'argent
à mettre le voyage donc on voit une
recrudescence de tout ce qui est
location de voitures de tout ce qui est
à court terme et comme c'est le cas au
canada un peu partout on voit énormément
de demandes pour tout ce qui est voyage
à l'intérieur du pays donc et les vols
de trois heures une destination à
l'autre à partir du canada les
destinations les plus prisées à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment vancouver
toronto cas de ricky la même chose qu'on
voit chaque année et à l'international
c'est nos cousins américains qui
bénéficient le mans
les canadiens s'en vont principal dans
le gard classe arjel las vegas qui sont
à commander les jours ça s'est accéléré
les principales destinations estivales
bon avec kopin évidemment vous vous
targuer d'être un des moyens les plus
efficaces là pour réserver au meilleur
prix mais comment vont vos affaires ça a
été peut-être un peu plus difficile
pendant la pandémie mais depuis les
assouplissements sanitaire le qui ont
permis la relance comment ça se passe
nous on est en ce moment à peu près à
500% de de la volume qu'on faisait avant
la pandémie dont on essaie une fois que
de rouille à quelles raisons pour ça ce
qui est derrière la croissance et la
raison pourquoi il ya tant de gens qui
depuis cette application première fois
ci nous produits d'assurance par exemple
ce rappeur vous avez la possibilité de
protéger votre connexion si le vol est
en retard d'une heure peu importe la
raison
vous ouvrez l'application et tous les
vols sont gratuits pour vous rendre à
votre destination c'est en fait on a
aussi des produits qui permettent de
rendre des vols non remboursables et
remboursables
les changements ou si vous attrapez la
commune simplement et ses produits
d'assurance là évidemment son ultra
populaire dans un environnement où on a
autant de vols sont annulés autant de
dérangement et autant de raisons de
croire changer si date ou d'annuler son
vol l'algue rouge de croissance repose
sur cette suite de produits commençaient
bon alors on vous souhaite bonne chance
pour la suite des choses merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous
c'est pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh